hello and welcome to see you're playing
Galbraith a Vienna a game okay hmm hmm
ok I'll try that one how does that work
actually it's 96 that much unknown check
yeah and now it's Queenie seven right
and I it's not very exciting maybe I
should have said something else but
again it's not the end of the world
proven 935 it's a bit like it's a bit
like them on the Berlin with rookie one
very very similar kind of position okay
what is he going for here do you form
probably just wants to play deform okay
I think our castle first and now see ok
c 3 and d 4 is this idea that bishop is
not very active so probably rook e8
we had to put it on d6 on f6 the bishop
probably d6 and quite unclear yeah i
don't i don't have 97 unfortunately came
Jeff very equal ish not the camera kind
of gain that you want when you I close
to getting to 2500 but the issue was
that context e5 is such a boring move
there is also there are some other some
other options that are bit more
interesting what you didn't go for them
yeah how does he play this now probably
very slowly like Bishop detune ig3 this
one I don't quite see the idea we just
want to cover to iona taking e 5 and g5
I Bishop a force was his plan I'm sorry
I should have seen that okay hmm okay
that wasn't the plan it seems so it's
Sam can I go if I go g5 here's this
somewhat it's that shaky or anything I
don't think so I need to get some kind
of ID am take some space one idea
definitely white has winning on time
because I've spent a bit of time no it's
not so bad i'm taking a bit of space IAM
maybe h5 okay what does he want to do f
4g for something like that not quite
sure take making a little improvement g4
i can go to h4 and this one okay
heading 43 yeah maybe okay so this is
this is interesting and let's trade it
and now on f4 I have G 493 maybe I don't
know hmm I don't have time to consider
this carefully okay I think I'm
preventing rg3
c4 really c4f bishop deform doesn't
really do much so a three is coming off
probably yes okay i won 116 that's not
good
they don't have a very clear plan he
wants to probably cut this off
time morning yeah I know I know I don't
want to make it wrong here it's probably
a wise too soon because of the time but
still don't like it cd5 I was thinking
night before is good I reckon he could
have taken could have taken g5 I guess
yeah I know I'm a piece
29 seconds check not much and which
should be should be doable check check
check
I want to keep that pawn makes things a
little bit simpler check this is safe
now and I think I just go beat you and
win this now neighborhood to take even
more stuff check check check check check
check mate ok yeah it is not enough for
2500 but it's closed for 696 poor have a
tough game yeah he really played them
played it very close to the west yeah I
think we should be 3 is the more
interesting movie about that ok here's
it's tough I think I probably have to
play Queen you seven and there's this
move
this and tiara is covering this yeah
this is this is really boring it's equal
but it's also boring yeah try to do
something but in the process kind of
yeah made made it made it difficult to
play in a way yeah not sure about all
this I mean the computer likes my
position that I'm not entirely sure we
had a repetition and now this for night
before which he did not address at all
night before yeah it says something else
Knight c3 repeats given by the engine
yeah then why tis ok equal and tiered
gets it gets tricky yeah this was this
was not exactly the test but and he has
to take I think I recapture and from
here you can definitely try to fight I
mean I'm attacking this and if the
bishop moves he to fall so he will even
lose some stuff and maybe this one check
this one line with the pawn yeah like is
this better here but it's tricky but
this is making it a lot easier with them
just just a pawn yeah and okay 30
seconds but it was a bit too easy I'm
almost impossible to screw up okay
thanks for watching